his queen so
this one just looks so natural
blockading but he drops it back one
square wow wow
wow what has happened the computer
thinks because what has happened it's a
huge shock so just to explain white now
has swung the queen across and magnus
has put his queen on a bad square
because now the move he wants to play is
to bring his rook across hitting the
white queen but now knight takes bishop
would be winning because black has put
his queen on the wrong square there's no
time to take the white knight because
the rook would fall off and they both
they both have a great body language i
mean magnus head head is phenomenal
that's good news for your bet oh yeah
oh get in there
come on
come on well what is the most likely now
with this chaos
reacting he knows yeah he blundered yeah
yeah he just put his queen on a square
within range of the white knight now
knight takes bishop will always hit the
black queen
and uh yeah it's
he knows it's just careless it's
complacent maybe he thought he was just
winning instantly and he's reacting look
at us cursing himself and yeah it's
gonna be hard to come back from that
though yeah because i mean you know
queen b8 is probably just game over and
you need to ask for more from the
position by introducing the bishop and
oh he does
he does go for it but okay now it's
napoleon who has to force the draw and
look at him he's smiling he has to
repeat moves otherwise white is about to
get checkmated and there we go more
drama in this match but it's a draw
again and they're both shaking their
head again it's like an incredible day
chess
incredible four draws